ينضم الينا من عمان الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه اللواء فايز الدويري لواء
فايز الدويري مرحبا بك معنا
اذا اقرت اوكرانيا بان الهجوم المضاد قد
بدا ولكن هل هو الهجوم المضاد الاكبر
الاوسع وما هي خطوط هذا الهجوم
حدث ان هذه هي العمليات تعتبر عمليه
تحضيريه او تمهيديه من اجل انجاح الهجوم
المضاد الرئيسي لا اعتقد حتى هذه اللحظه
التي اتحدث بها ان الهجوم المضاده الرئيسي
قد بدا لماذا
رغم المعارك ورغم الحديث والخسائر وما
شابه ذلك لا تزال المعارك في اطار
تكتيكي محدود مؤطر حجم القوات المشاركه
استنادا الى تصريحات وزير الدفاع الروسي
شويغو قدرها بلواء وبالتالي هذا الكم من
القوات اذا اعتمدناه كمقاربه تحليليه هو
لا يشكل نسبه كبيره ويعتد بها من حجم
القوات الاوكرانيه التي تم تحضيرها
المعدات التي وصلت وبناء مركز دراسات
الحرب هي تستطيع ان تؤهل
وتحضر تسعه الويه مدرعه وصل تقريبا 500
دبابه وصل الفي عربه قتال ما بين عربه
مصفحه وعربه
عربه دعم قتالي لوحدات المشاه
وصلها 300 منظومه متعدده
الفتحات وصلى حوالي الف مدفع اذا هذا الكم
الكبير من المعدات ويجهز تسعه الويه اي
بمعنى يجهز تقريبا ثلاثه فرق يجهز فيلق
القوات المشاركه لا تزال دون ذلك بكثير
ولا ترقى الى مستوى فرقه ناقص اذا هذا هذا
يقودنا الى القول ان ما يجري حاليا
هي المرحله التمهيديه
ومرحله التحضير من اجل حسابات متعدده اولا
استطلاع بالقوه لتحديد نقاط الضعف والقوه
في الجدار الدفاعي والخطه الدفاعيه تحديد
الثغرات في الخطوط الدفاعيه من اجل تطوير
هذه الهجمات اي بمعنى اخر الانجازات في
هذه المرحله ستعتبر نقاط ارتكاز وانطلاق
للقوات القادمه والتي هي تعتبر القوه
الضاربه في الجيش الاوكراني المطلوب منها
الوصول الى تكمت او ميلوتوبل او ماريوبل
او جسر كرش
القوات هي تعمل المرحله التحضيريه عن هذه
المرحله وعن الحرب النفسيه حتى الان وكان
الكره المبادره هي لدى الجانب الاوكراني
هو من سيقوم بهذا الهجوم المضاد وهناك حرب
نفسيه شاهدنا قبل قليل وفي الايام الماضيه
ايضا تصريحات
ما هي ملامح هذه الحربه النفسيه
يا سيدي الان
ابقت الضبابيه والغموض على العمليه
العسكريه والرئيس جلنسكي تحدث ان العمليه
الهجوم الهجوم بدا ولكن لن اتحدث عن ايه
مرحله وبالتالي هي تبقي القوات الروسيه في
حاله ترقب هل هذه القوه هي القوه المهاجمه
هل هذه هي القوه التي تمثل المرحله الاولى
من العمليات لان المراحل القادمه هي
المراحل الحاسمه هذه المرحله هي مرحله
تحضير للمراحل اللاحقه بمعنى اخر ما هي
حدود المرحله الاولى هل المرحله الاولى
تتعامل مع الخط الدفاعي الاول
وستنهك الخط الدفاعي الاول وستفتح ثغرات
في الجدار الدفاعي سيستخدمها الجيش
الاوكراني خاصه ان الخلفيه الذهنيه للمخطط
الروسي
والقاضي الميدانيين هي معركه خاركيف معركه
خاركيف كانت مقاربتها مختلفه اعتمدت
عمليات الاختراق العميق والسريع وعمليات
الاحاطه والانتفاق وبالتالي اجبرت القوات
الروسيه على اخلاء مواقعها والانسحاب حتى
هذه اللحظه هي معركه مواجهه مختلفه كليا
عن معركه خاركيف لماذا هذا اعتقد ان
الغايه منه هي كشف نقاط الضعف الثغرات في
الجدار الدفاعي انهاك القوات المدافعه خلق
نقاط ارتكاز وانطلاق من اجل المناوره
اللاحقه خاصه ان هناك اشارات ان المستشاري
ان الضباط الامريكيين او المستشاريين
الامريكيين هم وضعوا بصمات لهم على الخطه
الهجوميه وهي كذا كان ذلك دقيقا
القتاليه الامريكيه معروفه لا تعتمد
المواجهه المفتوحه في العمليات الهجوميه
تعتمد دائما وابدا على عمليات هجوم محدود
كمعارك صداميه ولكنها تعتمد من اجل حجم
المعركه على عمليات الاختراق والانتفاخ طب
لواء فايز
هذه العقيده الامريكيه التي تتحدث عنها
بانه يجري اعتمادها من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه هل يمكن دمجها مع العقيده التي
يعتمدها اساسا تعتمدها القوات الاوكرانيه
في مثل هذه المواجهه لاكتشاف نقاط الضعف
وهل لاحظت مثلا وجود هذه النقاط التي تحدث
بانها تدخل ضمن اساسيات المرحله الاولى
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه دعينا اقول في
البدايه منذ عام 2014 والخبراء الامريكيين
موجودين ويقوموا بتدريب الضباط
الاوكرانيين وبالتالي انتقلت انتقل انتقل
الفكر العسكري لدى الضابط في الجيش
الاوكراني من العقيد القتاليه للجيش
الاحمر والجيش الروسي لانه معظمهم خريجي
المعاهد الحرب ومعاهد الاركان الروسيه الى
تبني العقائد القتاليه الغربيه التي تعتمد
على الحرب المتحركه اكثر من اعتمادها على
الهجوم الجبهوي واسع النطاق المعتمد لدى
الجيش الروسي لكن في هذه في هذا في هذه
المعارك او في هذا الهجوم يبدو ان لا تسال
الان المقاربه الاولى هي مقاربه غربيه
لانها هجمات محدوده واكد هجمات محدوده على
نقاط محدده لاحدى لاضعاف الخط الدفاعي
احداث اختراق ات خلق نقاط ارتكاز تسمح
للقوات القادمه من الخلف بالاندفاع الى ما
وراء الخطوط الدفاعيه عند ذلك نبدا نتحدث
عن توك ماك وعن
وماريوبل وبحر ازوف اذا قيد للمرحله
الاولى ان تنجح شكرا لك لواء فايزه
الدويريه الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
حدثتنا من عمان